this video is going to show how to find
data on NCBI specifically on the
sequence for you to archive on SRA and
to use that data on the T bio info
platform where you can analyze theta
without having to download it to your
computer without having to upload it
back to the platform so let's say I am
interested in finding some data set to
work with let's say it's a gene
expression data so I'm going to go to
NCBI I can just search on Google for
NCBI and I will find this website right
here now as you know NCBI is the
National Center for Biotechnology
information collect contains a lot of
different options for you to find data
some data is processed for example you
can find some process gene expression
omnibus datasets in the geo database you
can also find the raw sequences on SRA
so let's say I'm interested in diabetes
and there's a recent article that came
out and that recent article is going to
come from a data set let's just find
here an article you can see a public PC
are present in a unique dual receptor
expressing lymphocyte from type one
diabetes patients encoded in a potent
t-cell Auto antigen so this paper was
published in cell press how do we find
the data and that was published with
this paper this paper is published in
2019 what we need to do is we can go
down here we can start seeing related
information and here we have the Geo
data set this will be the gene
expression data from this data and we
can also find the sequence read archive
what's in the sequence read archive are
the raw files fast queue files from this
experiment so you can see all of the
different files there's a total of 77 of
them and how do we find the actual data
well what we can do is we can go right
here to send to click on file and here
in format we can select run info and
file so it's going to download a file
you can see that the file downloaded and
I can look at this file now I'm not
going to take all of the 77 files what I
would rather do is take a subset of
those files so here I've selected nine
files some are dual expresser some where
B cell and some are T cell and what I'm
also going to look for is the
information about what kind of
sequencing was done how do I find that
here I can see that these are fast queue
files that are packaged in SRA and I can
also see that these are paired and
library layout reads and this is
transcriptomic data in other words it's
gene expression data measured in the
transcriptomic data and now I can go to
server that T - bio that info and I will
arrive at the T value in for platform
the T value in for platform allows you
to process these kinds of datasets
easily using our cloud infrastructure
you can request an account by just going
here and clicking on access and filling
out this form so I'm going to go right
here under RNA seek cheap parallel
analysis of NGS and microarray data I'm
going to click here now as you remember
I saw that this was paired and read so
I'm just going to change this to PE if I
look at what organism this was it says
right here the homo sapiens or human so
I'm going to find here the latest
Assembly of the human genome which is
grch38 and click on file upload now I
don't have the raw files all I have is
the SRA run table and I saved this SRA
run table let's do it again let's do
file save as we can't upload in Excel
what we will do is use tab delimited
text so here I have the name of the
project I'm just going to delete any
extra characters here
and call this selected right because I
already selected several files from all
of the links that I have I'm going to
save this and this is just warning me
that I am NOT going to be able to save
Excel features which I don't need the
Excel feature just need the raw
tab-delimited txt format now I'm going
to go back here and here you can see
NCBI run table upload so I'm going to
add files and here I have this file that
I just prepared selected go to choose
you can see that it uploads and shows
you a hundred percent and now I can go
to group selection and now I would like
to compare for example my dual expresses
versus all the other ones so the dual
expressed are the ones that are let's
look over here do all express ourselves
or the first three ones and then I have
six other ones B cells and T cells so
I'm just going to put the first three
right here in Group A and all the rest I
will put in Group B and now do contrasts
I'm just going to have all of the
contrast that are possible in other
words the first group first the second
group the second group versus the first
group all of the contrasts and now I can
build my pipeline so the pipeline I will
build I will do some pre-processing
steps to remove any of the library prep
technical sequences then I am going to
go to bow tie to t2 map on the genome
generate an awesome expression table and
here I will use expected count because I
want to do differential gene expression
afterwards
I'm just going to click here or I can
also use edge R as another option so
let's try edge R as well and let's click
on end and I'm going to just save this
so diabetes cell lines or now these are
T or dual expressor versus T
and b-cells type 1 diabetes suppressor
and I'm just going to say that this is
edge our and run this pipeline now when
this pipeline finishes running you will
see that the files have been uploaded
directly from NCBI from the SRA archive
and directly uploaded on platform and
also saved under your account so you can
use them later on that's it for today
and thanks again for checking it